hi good morning from San Diego I'm going
to Starbucks right now we've got it on
the map I did the mobile order a think
it's gonna take six minutes to get there
it says three to seven minutes for my
order
and then I'm super excited because we're
gonna go to the zoo and we're gonna do
this Caravan giraffe Safari and in the
notes it says there's an opportunity for
giraffe eats that made me a little
nervous cuz it was like dad you're gonna
give us the opportunity but what if the
giraffes aren't hungry what if the
giraffes don't like set my snack oh it's
really bright we've made it to the
Safari we're heading in I thought this
is the same thing as the San Diego Zoo
but apparently it's different so I've
never been here before
this is all just a new adventure it's
backless but there's a sign there are
you ready I'm ready let's do it there's
so many different Safari things you can
do I also want to do there's a way
it's like a trach it survives you can
like ride on a little bicycle oh my gosh
there's so many so everybody has hats on
and I feel like that's something that I
might need I might need a safari hat
this would match my outfit a little too
much you think like I already look like
an idiot I mean I've got all pink on and
I'm wearing a GoPro on my chest so I am
filming with like a 4k DSLR camera this
is a high production value I'll put the
hats for me there's something that
happens I can't even see it but I know
it's not good
oh I just think edges like me
cool okay
if you look back here it's look right
only only blackboards exactly anyone
know why a draft on this dark Sun the
Sun yes so did we get sunburned so no
selfies no it's just why I am feeding
him while she is taking the picture
because we've had too many people get
injured
what happened he's weak because if
somebody's not paying attention to him
he's like
don't know that I wanna be with you
you can buy your way into my heart but
you don't see that I just won yeah so
the caravan riot it was pretty much the
coolest thing that I have ever done it
was so cool you got to see so many
animals it's our tour guide Megan if you
guys ever come here request Megan
because she was incredible why it's
pretty hot today it was real cool
earlier in the morning Wow
this is my third coffee slush you know
second second coffee slush me the day
we're now leaving Safari Park San Diego
Zoo Safari Park different from the San
Diego Zoo definitely recommend it come
check it out it's serious it was the
coolest thing ever
there's so much other stuff we did get
to see but I think I'm gonna pass out
from heat exhaustion and caffeine
overdose and read some of our ways to
drive back home so that's it see you
later oh I love the tree there's a cute